the man back in the super bowl he made
it with the team in his first year with
the rams it's sean mcvay's first year
interestingly enough though this time
around he's taking on the team that
drafted him he is andrew whitworth here
again on the rich eisen show how are you
andrew
i'm good rich appreciate you having me
on man thanks for joining all right um
congrats
uh what's going through your mind right
now as you're tooling around los angeles
right now man it's uh you know what it's
it's wild rich it's hard to get it all
together you know it's it's that day
where you're happy and then you're also
just trying to figure out how you got
where you are and a lot of excitement
and all that but uh be a fun two weeks
that's for sure i know um and uh so what
take me into the locker room last night
after it was all over what was that like
oh man you know that whole thing on the
field and the celebration and just you
know just it gets uh you know just a
great a great opportunity to show your
gratitude to all the people in the
building that make up what uh what is
your organization and that was a lot of
fun a lot of great energy and
really just a special moment you get to
have with all those people that you know
not just the players but everybody
that's been so invested all throughout
the year and getting to that pinnacle
really means a lot to so many different
people and families and everything else
it was really special the hugs the
embraces the pictures
and just the overall excitement of
everybody speaking of hug and embracing
we're showing a photograph right now
andrew of you sharing one with sean
mcvay
can you let us be a fly on the wall what
was this one like when you saw him last
night
what'd you say uh really special i mean
obviously our relationship has been
extremely unique in the five years we've
been here together and and um
you know i think something to us you
know a lot it's been a lot of time on
and off the field spinning together
philosophy over ball and culture and
everything else and so uh
it's always always really cool we get to
share some of those moments uh where we
get to enjoy some of the some of the
long talks the long evenings that we
spend
uh talking about what's right and and
enjoying what you know we've been able
to both be a part of and build here in
l.a is this i mean when you're going you
through your process you and your wife
and family about doing this one more
time
is this what you dreamt of obviously
andrew i mean i don't know if i could
have dreamed a better scenario uh
than really how this year's played out
and
um in a lot of different ways richmond i
think there's you know things you're
involved in and things you're not i mean
even having some games where i've had to
miss for injury and having a young guy
like joe noteboom that i've
you know mentored since the day he got
here and see him come in and play well
and get and win games for us and
and then you know you almost get to see
the totality of all of it and then some
of the things that we've been able to do
and young guys rise up and
uh it's just been so special and then
now to be to glenn a franchise i've
poured my heart and soul into for 11
years and
uh you know for them to be where they
are and have a relationship with all of
those folks
i couldn't be more grateful honestly
just it's uh as i said my heart's full
for both both franchises and i can't
wait i mean your wife tweeted out a
photograph of you embracing saying it's
all worth it
so
that's got to be cool to see that from
your wife right andrew yeah i mean it's
uh it is you know there's a lot that
goes into it you know sacrificing things
that you get to be around for your kids
for and and different family moments and
and uh you know and there's a lot of
sacrifices that
my wife makes and my kids make for me to
get to do this and um
you know i think it uh makes it all
worthwhile when you get to these kind of
moments andrew whitworth here on the
rich eisen show and again it is kind of
wild it's the bengals too and an lsu
quarterback quarterbacking them too
andrew this is kind of freaky to me
it is you know i mean uh to think that
uh last december
joe joe burrow is fresh off of his uh
acl
surgery and i'm i'm uh trying to rehab a
pcl and mcl tear and we're sitting in my
house watching nfl football games
together on a sunday both in crutches
and
knee braces and then now for us to be
playing each other in the super bowl
uh it's it's just been a wild year i'll
put it that way so you and joe borrow
rehab together
andrew no he just we have the same team
doc dr ella right his surgery and so i
had never actually met joe or talked to
him while he was at lsu i sent him some
messages over the time he was there but
we've never met
uh and obviously when he got to
cincinnati uh through me knowing zach
taylor really well you know i i got to
hear about him a lot but when i heard
that he was out here in l.a doing his
rehab with dr ella trash
i reached out to him and he came over to
the house and um we spent some time
together watching nfl football and
um and then he also came over for the
draft when they drafted jamar chase this
year so we've uh we've had some times to
hang out and get to know each other over
the last year and and uh now for
supposed to be in the super bowl is uh
pretty crazy dude
i i did not know that so he's at the
draft and he that's how he learns
officially that jamar chase
lsu teammate was going to be his
professional teammate you're all lsu
tigers together
i mean yeah we're coming into my house
watching watching the draft together so
then i guess your impressions of joe
burrow then before we get to your
quarterback oh i mean i you know i've
always been on record saying he's going
to be really special at that time i got
to spend with him last year when he was
injured just hearing how his mind works
and really just the way he's wired
uh extremely rare and he's going to be a
real special one for a really long time
and
i've walked away from that day i spent
with him thinking that uh
wow you know here's the next you know
the next painting the next tom the next
i mean what drew bree whoever you want
to call it this guy is extremely
extremely rare and he's going to be a
really good one for a long time andrew
whitworth here on the rich eisen show
what does making the super bowl mean for
stafford the guy who's back you
literally and figuratively have
andrew
oh i think it's so awesome i mean when
you look at a guy like staff and really
how good he's been but just hasn't been
in a great situation for so long to come
here and take advantage of the op i mean
you know it's it's it's all this
pressure when you get him that he you
know had to take on and it's like
everyone expects you to do this and that
but you still have to go out and perform
you still have to actually make it all
come to life and and for him to do that
and lead us the way he has
uh man i can't imagine what a feeling
it's got to be a gratification for him
to not only have the pressure and the
expectation to be a difference maker but
to actually be it
uh it's got to be a really cool feeling
and something that gives you a you know
a real
positive belief in yourself and what
you're capable of to be able to see it
through like this yeah i mean it's a
perfect way to put it you know to he to
have it and then be it
that is that is it sounds so simple but
it is so very difficult how was he last
night when you got a chance to have
maybe a quiet moment with him yeah i
mean we spent some time after the game
and then uh and then later that night we
got together a little bit and yeah i'm
just emotional and you could tell just
so grateful
uh you know and that's who he is i mean
his characters
is second to none he's an awesome guy an
awesome human and and uh that's that's
what makes it fun as well and so
um i'm sure he's enjoying his girls and
and his wife kelly and then we're
probably spending some time being
grateful today and and uh they should be
i mean we're we're grateful to have him
we're grateful for what he's done to get
us where we are
and uh i i can't imagine he's i can
imagine he's probably pretty emotional
today and what about a fellow lsu tiger
in odell what does it mean do you think
for him
your teammate to make the super bowl
here in los angeles after him coming
here middle of the season andrew
whitworth you think of that yeah it's
wild you know rich all these things fall
into place i can remember actually when
we were in the super bowl against the
patriots in in the end of 18 season
uh seeing o'dell at one of the uh the
nflpa events and uh him giving me a hug
and begging for a chance for us to play
together and i was talking about it
really since then we've always just kind
of chatted about it
and for it to come to life this year uh
it's just been so crazy
and uh here we are with an opportunity
to go play in a super bowl and uh get a
chance to try and
hoist that lombardi so i you know it's
one of those things all just seems to
come together for a really cool moment
and
and uh like i said i mean i i couldn't
be more ecstatic about the situation and
circumstance of this whole thing and who
i'm doing it with
so um do you think this might not have
happened if uh y'all didn't run into
stafford in cabo about a year ago
this time
yeah i mean pretty wild to think that uh
exactly a year ago yesterday um that
happened and the trade went through so
it's a while been a wild year as we said
last night what what a 365 days that's
been
and uh you know what it's
unbelievable it's a script for a movie
or something i don't know it's it's
pretty wild and i just in a few minutes
i have left with you andrew whitworth i
was talking about how the niners had an
opportunity
to win on your turf right and play the
super bowl on your turf and that would
be a calling card that they could place
onto the rams every single year
forevermore i'm wondering if that was
part of yesterday obviously the trip to
the super bowl is there's no higher
stakes other than the game you're about
to play
but i'm wondering if that crept into
your minds like not on that field not in
that manner not on that day
yesterday andrew yeah i'm sure
throughout the week those thoughts you
know go through your mind of uh how
rough a couple weeks that would probably
be for for you um having them be in your
city and enjoying a super bowl trip and
and possibly winning one
would be tough and you know but at the
end of the day the biggest thing we knew
is that
they are an extremely good football team
and have a lot of really good football
players and we knew we were going to
have to play our absolute best and
there's gonna be bumps along the road
and we're gonna have to be in that thing
till the very last second
and um you know what it proved to be
that way but man what a football team
they are i mean i couldn't have more
respect for a team and their players and
really the way they operate and how they
compete i mean it's been
extremely impressive to watch this
season and we knew it was going to take
our best to win i know and i know it's a
it's a sensitive subject but i'm going
to go there anyway the the idea that you
have to go silent snap count so often in
your building uh with with a die hard
uh nails um rival uh on the other side
what what is that like
andrew yeah it's tough it is tough it's
a tough situation but you know what um
they have a great following a great
crowd that uh that follows them it's all
kind of always been that way i can
remember even in cincinnati when they'd
come there um a few times replied i'm
just what a what a insane following of
crowds and how well they travel and
stuff and it's impressive but uh it
makes it tough but it also makes it
every bit of sweet man because all those
people got to watch us win
[Laughter]
it's a good answer um all right and
that's a really nice way right there you
know what because you know i say your
instagram too i don't know if you want
to visit that here or not but you know
um about tickets and things like that
andrew oh yeah it's all good okay all
right so uh last one for you i'll just
come straight out and ask you do you
think super bowl 56 is your last game oh
andrew whitworth
what do you think uh
i'm pretty confident i would say it's a
much higher percentage that it is than
it isn't so
um you know for us i just i think it's
coming that point in my life where i'm
ready to do something else and
i've had a lot of fun i got a lot of
people here i love and invested in and
i'm ready to watch them do their thing
and uh i'm gonna try and go out one last
ride and then so if this is in fact all
right um
what does it mean that you did it
you came back man you rehabbed you came
back
and you are in the super bowl not just
that but it is a home super bowl you
stay in your home i'm assuming um you
know what does that mean
andrew for you uh you know it's
something i think i'll have a better
grasp on over the years but you know
right now uh just something that's like
you know it's hard for me to not get
emotional to even think about just um to
overcome really last year's injury and
to be where i'm at and to be in this
moment and have helped us get to where
we are
um it's really special for me and my
family and we know the dedication it
took and really the blessings and
everything that were involved to be
where we are
and and more importantly to be doing it
with people that we couldn't love and
appreciate and
be happier to be doing it with and um
that that's what's made it really
special for me is when i look across our
building there's so many people that i
want to go in for and every single week
and
i think that's what makes it special and
then something we really enjoy and
uh we're just we're just very very
extremely grateful
to be where our feet are and um
couldn't be happier to have it all
happen like this i mean
to play cincinnati a place we care and
love love so much and have a lot of
people there we believe in and
uh care about and then also to be here
and invested and love this building
uh what a cool story i love it i love it
andrew i couldn't be happier for you
really couldn't be happier for you and
your family congratulations on all i
appreciate it richard you got it oh last
one for you are you gonna be in your in
the visitors locker room are the bengals
taking your locker room do they have the
ability to do that for the super bowl
uh i think that the locker rooms we're
still in hours and they're in the other
one but um i'm not totally sure on that
but i think that somebody told me that
um last week yeah i think we're still in
our locker room okay because you know
it's been a long time since you took
your stuff out of a locker so the you
know you know like this yeah i think the
way sofa is built
there's multiple so oh
my bad
yeah they had some money left over after
the five and a half billion is what
you're saying my bad my bad there's a
little space in there okay fantastic
andrew congrats let's talk over the next
couple weeks i'll i'll i'll reach out
thanks for the time
appreciate it rich you're the best
that's the best for andrew whitworth
right there a super bowl 56 left tackle
at the age of 40. hey you watched all
the way to the end thanks for that watch
more right here